welcome back to new rockstars spiderman
no way home has the table
set with a guest list from across the
multiverse if it chooses to do so
thanks to the way loki and what if our
breaking up the marvel timeline
is it gonna be pizza time with toby or
not well
this is rogue theory it's a show where
we pitch the
wildest theories and nerdy things uh
that are often
not correct but sometimes are and those
are the only things we pretended
we said i'm eric voss going rogue with
me today
are mastertainment mt hey what's going
on i'm ready to go rogue
and comedian and writer and number one
thanos stan
jessica clements don't say that
don't say that don't say anything i
don't write
i make comedy and i love thanos and
that's it also prolific gamer and twitch
streamer and good friend of the show
angelica tray
all right guys another week has gone by
another week without
spider-man no way home trailer to uh
complete our lives
but loki has opened some portals a
possibility to explain how the hell that
movie will
work no way home is confirmed to include
alfred molina's dock and jamie foxx's
electro along with dr
strange those cassies alone suggest we
are looking at a multiverse story
but fans are still clinging to hope that
alternate peter parkers like toby
maguire and andrew garfield will appear
as well
as long as everyone else who's ever been
in a marvel associated title
from willing to foe to charlie cox
though thankfully
thanks to loki we now have a new word
for what those ultimate peters could be
the big a lie earth i'm just kidding
variants variants they'd be variants of
course
yes uh but in order to understand what
that would even mean to the spider-verse
we still have to figure out what exactly
happens to someone when they get pruned
one of the many leftover questions we
still have after loki
like is their whole home timeline erased
from existence as well when they set
that reset charge or
just the circumstances related to their
nexus event and when they're taken by
the tva
are they then missing from that home
timeline could that connect to that set
photo we saw from spiderman no way home
of missing children
is no way home gonna use terms like
variants in tva to explain where their
characters came from
ultimately i think the real question is
is it more or less likely that toby
mcgregor and andrew garfield will appear
in no way home
now what do you guys think it's more
likely for them to appear
of course i'm excited to see some spidey
variants
but in terms of there's a lot to unpack
right with with what you just said
i previously thought they pruned the
entire timeline because
of the terminology that they used in
loki but
now i'm thinking after seeing the end of
time in that whole area
there wasn't that much stuff there
really wasn't so i'm thinking about it
there could have been more
a little bit more stuff yeah there's
like five buildings
max so i feel like it was
they they just take out all of the stuff
around the nexus events
including that pizza car that owen
wilson uh
mobius's character drove i think that
that had a big hand in one of the nexus
events
yeah it's like is it only relevant
evidence and whatever their trial
was uh like it would one thing would
imply
in order to not create some other kind
of confusing netflix
netflix paradox i almost said netflix
i meant nexus paradox you can't just
leave timelines without these people
in them then other things get confused
right if there's
no loki if there's no classic loki no
gator loki i don't want to live in a
world without a gator location right um
but i think like the implication of the
show like maybe the writers didn't ask
himself this question
is that yeah that enough of their
timeline was erased
and that the only things that are
variant about that timeline are the
things that are
related to what made it a variance
therefore
if you did just poop it on down to the
void eliath would eat most of it anyway
i feel like we're trying to divide by
zero just like really complicated
recycles or something too for new
timelines you know there's
okay all right i could see that i think
he's just hungry i think he eats entire
universes that could prove down there
i think that's the idea oh yeah he's a
clown he is just a
newborn puppy he's a clown pup
but i think the reason i brought that up
is inter if they decide that andrew
garfield and tobin mcguire would be
variant peter parker's what would that
mean
for their realities that they came from
would it mean that
other things can't come from the raimi
verse
can he be the only variant thing that
comes from the remy first or could we
also see
you know because we know doc ock is
coming from there too can you have
multiple different variants come from
the same home universe
i think that it's possible that we could
get multiple variants from
um you know from one universe i mean we
have the andrew garfield universe
that didn't technically end and it
didn't it just sort of
ended on its own and then we got the tom
holland stuff but there's a ton of
unused elements that they were teasing
at the end of amazing spider-man 2 but
never actually got to
so we could see those elements pop into
the mcu through that way i feel
um but yeah i don't i don't think the
the the spider-man timelines
um you know the rainy verse or the
webverse um
you know were pruned by the tva i think
that
the this at the ending of loki probably
maybe even started those universes like
maybe those universes
hadn't started yet and then the
multiverses um branched out it's like
okay now
like the the old universes that we love
the x-men universe the spider-man
universes
they all start now and so um
you know then that's when we get those
multiversal elements but
i don't know i like that idea i think
the cleanest version of this would be
once something gets pruned from a
timeline the entire timeline doesn't get
pruned but rather
an alternate version of sylvie takes
that
uh pruned variance place and just uh
makes different decisions so that that
way the entire timeline doesn't get
pruned there's just like another
young sylvie that's that's sitting there
in asgard not
uh playing with their toys in a slightly
different way that doesn't lead to the
rise of a cat she's playing with her
bionicle toys like she should be
i truly i truly expected them to be gone
out of that timeline
like i just imagine they just reset it
and then the parents were just like we
never had a child
so oh like a hermione granger's parents
like a
wiping of their mind and just being like
we've never had a child so there's just
a time like a men in black
things yeah so there's a timeline where
sylvie just doesn't exist and the
parents were like we never wanted
children but they actually did have a
child
um the child just got taken away yeah i
think that's possible jess i just think
that
that gives too many butterfly effect
implications from that like if you just
remove someone even if the people who
are in their lives no longer think about
them
historically things get dramatically
altered from just one person especially
especially a significant person is loki
oh yeah gets removed from that world
so you're right we both could be i think
the real answer is we are thinking about
this harder than the people who worked
on the show
well also you know a bit something else
i'm skeptical about
is that the tva they did have some fancy
tech but it wasn't that fancy i don't
know if they can erase memories all they
can do is
use their zappy sticks and you know
travel between these timelines
but to do that full situation where
everyone forgets
everything in that entire timeline i
feel like that's really complex
well angelica um i we have to remember
that uh kang did have a nightmare
department
in the tva that we never really got into
and that's the realm of the mind
and that's where people's minds go when
they dream so maybe
he has some sort of type of influence
over the mind we know not all of us
only dream at the form of nightmare
empty some of us
are able to have pleasantries that's uh
that's only stephen king one thing that
loki i think the writers did consider is
the fact that just because someone gets
removed from wherever they were in the
timeline
doesn't mean that that timeline no
longer has that person of
uh them there so when loki got an
episode one gets pruned or he doesn't
get pruned yet right
he just gets arrested he gets taken out
of mongolia
but there's still another loki who's on
that timeline who's living out the
infinity saga as loki would have up to
the point of thanos choking him to death
so i think that's the idea of it is like
once
variants get removed they're just
unstuck from time but they're still a
doppelganger of themselves that's still
uh going through the motions of the way
they should have uh and it's
only when that variant started to step
away from their uh like
your mario kart ghost version of
yourself who you're currently racing
like there's another version of yourself
but they never showed us this other than
them so what so
it really is just headcanon speculation
theory right there i dig that that'd be
crazy but it's like
all right here's robert i'm trying to go
with though but i'm trying to go with
like the lamest
most irrational explanation just so we
could justify how we could have toby in
addition to doc
and andrew garfield in addition to
electro because otherwise if you say
that a variant who's pruned from a
timeline
erases the rest of the timeline they
came from then that makes it impossible
for toby and andrew logically to appear
and i don't want to live in that world
not the same world not the same world
not the same world but if we are looking
at that to the spider verse and really
get into the animation series where the
people did come out of those timelines
they were taken out of their homes and
it didn't seem like there was any kind
of replacement
so i'm not saying these are the two same
things but if what i do realize after
being on rogue theory a lot and just
coming up with my own theories is that
like oh it was simpler than what i
expected it to be
so i think i think thinking in those
terms of like yeah they just
disappeared and they were disappeared
for god knows how long it could be and
that's also the thing
it could be 20 minutes to them what was
like
three weeks in that universe we don't
know what time is going to be looking
like completely
so i mean i'm not sticking to my guns of
like sophie's dead
but i just like it's
using that logic they still just
disappeared in their whole
and their whole mindset was like i need
to get home yeah
i the reason i'm i'm sticking uh at
least my guns for the sake of this right
now is that
i um i do want like toby and andrew and
doc and all these other people
to show up in this movie um but i don't
want anything
to uh change what happened in the
original raimi trilogy as that history
played out
and like doc ock's death at the end of
spider-man 2 was beautiful in a way
and like i don't i still want that to be
true for that character
and his arc in the same way for all
these characters uh i don't want to make
it seem like
now it was retconned in a way okay so
like i like the idea of two different
versions of them and then like
he kind of splits into different branch
variants of himself so that there's
still
uh tobin mcguire who went through those
three movies they're still in jakarta
with those two movies and now we get
separate versions of them
who are just kind of confused and
they're in the mcu they barfed in
through a portal
but they're still like the version of
them that we knew in the heyday of those
movies like
whatever you know they were going
through and the moment they were plucked
okay
i get that i get that i feel it i
recognize i'm probably wrong
hey man we just speculating man this is
what broke through i'm out we're going
rogue
but can we uh each of us go rogue now
and just like try to conceive of
what the simplest sentence that
john watts is going to put in the script
for uh spider-man that we'll see in the
trailer
like what are what are they going to say
to try to explain how
these alternate universe people are the
same are going to be like they're from
the multiverse or they're variants or
they're going to be like
sometimes people just come from places
like what is it gonna be
sometimes people come from places i and
immediately i go oh that makes sense
yeah that's kind of right they do be
coming from places that is true people
do come from places
that's stupid i i don't think they're
gonna i mean they might use
variants but i don't know if they're
gonna use terms like the tva
yeah no way home i may be variants but
eventually they'll get to it it'll be
like a ding ding ding moment you know
i hope that they do sort of what they
did in um
you know the the spider-verse credits
with the spider-man 2099 and the og
spider-man just doing the pointing let's
just do the three-way pointing
like just don't no word just three-way
pointing like oh my god it's me
i really hope they meme it up like that
in the trailer
i feel like we're gonna get uh we're
gonna get peter parker being like
whoa like back to the future like
something stupid
but i think in the actual movie because
i
he knows who dr strange is so i think
he's gonna be like so like what doctor
strange does
like i feel like that's the best way
that peter parker's gonna understand
what's happening is he's gonna be like
oh so like they're coming out of holes
like they they found avengers so they're
the last avengers movie so he knows
that people can drop from portals he
knows that magic is a thing
you know what's probably gonna happen is
that peter oh peter peter and peter
toby andrew and tom i'm probably going
to explain what is happening to like
you know your uh your ned's or your your
mjs but like in the most nerdy way
possible because all three of them are
nerds
so they'll be like oh yeah no this is a
simple parallel universe blah blah blah
blah
kind of like with how peter goes on that
rant in um
in far from home about like multiverses
and all that stuff because they're all
nerds
so like they'll understand so like i
don't know i think it's a good
opportunity for a callback to that
moment like
peter's just like so you're telling me
there actually is
a multiverse i mean it really does
change everything that we thought about
the quantum singularity and then he cuts
himself off and he said
someone once told me not ever to
apologize for being the smartest one in
the room
but i'm sorry
i like that i like that yeah i
definitely
i could see peter being just genuinely
confused the whole movie
and him being like what's going on like
the whole time
i can't wait until he realizes all of
his different variants or his different
selves all have girlfriends too
so he's going to be like wait i'm
actually a mack daddy
and they're going to be like yeah
they're actually pretty good but andrew
garfield is just like but one of
what mine died
like charlie brown i got it wrong all of
your girlfriend's spines are intact
what yeah wait a minute
you will be crazy because the the
actress who played agatha harkness also
played
the role of a doc ock in the into the
spider burst movies
so like what if uh catherine hahn i
don't know why i blanked on her name
like
literal goddess on earth um kathy my
friend kathy
what if what if we got like a katherine
han variant of doc ock
in spider-man from those universes like
just straight up put capital let's do it
i would love it because she's already
you know in the mcu like
that would further drive home the idea
of variance
i like that idea so much um the golden
rogi
is going to go to angelica though
because uh
i think honestly the best way they could
do this movie is just
have peter and everyone confused as
this whole movie
and that way no one's an expert and
everyone's just like what's going on
and the answer is i don't know i don't
know what's going on
but we have multiple people then
we'll be the experts i'm confused you're
confused all the spideys are pointing at
each other and then it's pizza time
rap credits yeah i think one of the my
favorite lines in a movie
is in uh looper when it's like uh
it's bruce willis and joseph horton
levitt playing future and younger
versions of themselves
arguing about time travel and bruce
willis goes look we can be here all day
talking about this
drawing diagrams on napkins and we still
won't understand it's like the best like
justification
look time travel doesn't make sense no
matter how you argue it it's just not
going to make sense let's just move on
please and
it was great i was sold i was sold at
that point um
well we want to start looking at
marvel's what if which is a days away at
this point
but a great way to support our channel
and all the content we have here
is to check out our merch over at new
rockstarsmerch.com you can check out our
most recent latest obsession shirt
bad company inspired by the suicide
squad
which should be out by the time you're
watching this we've only got a limited
supply of those so be sure to grab one
before the tiny bomb
inside your head explodes you know cause
like suicide squad
uh just go yeah go show your support for
new rockstars at newrockstarsmerch.com
well we want to thank wondering for
sponsoring this episode you know who
stan lee
is of course the huge impact he had on
marvel comics the entertainment industry
as a whole
but what fewer fans might know is that
in the early 2000s stan lee was in some
financial trouble and on the verge of
suing marvel
who would do that who would who would
sue
disney just marvel comics not marvel
yeah
but the all-new season of the business
movers podcast
explores how stan lee changed the comic
book industry and saved his own career
in the process
each new season of business movers
you'll hear how titans of industry rose
from the bottom rung of the corporate
ladder
and what obstacles they overcame on
their climb to the top i'm excited for
this podcast
and more people to know about the part
of stan lee's life between
when he was streaming up the fantastic
four in spider-man and when he was
popping up
in mcu cameos in the movies on business
movers you'll find out exactly how a kid
from the bronx born at the height of the
great depression went on to become a
comic book industry superhero
listen to the latest episode of business
movers stan lee on apple music apple
podcasts
or you can listen ad free by joining one
direct
in the wondery app wondering feel the
story
we also want to thank expressvpn for
sponsoring this episode
look we all like privacy and we
especially need that privacy when we're
surfing the internet
well i hate to break it to you folks but
isps like comcast
verizon they know every single website
you visit
they they talk about it in their break
rooms they
do horrible things with this information
they might even sell the information to
ad companies and tech giants who then
use your data to target you and then
more and more people in the san
francisco bay area are just
forming lists about you and selling it
to third parties
and they create these creepy
hyper-targeted ads for the products that
you googled
or just talked about with your friends
out loud and then your devices were
listening to you
i'm sorry i'm really painting a scary
picture but it's not that
inaccurate well no matter what your fear
is
expressvpn creates a secure encrypted
tunnel
a tube some might say in the early years
the internet between your device
and the internet just you just your
device and the internet no other people
can peep in on your online activity when
you use expressvpn it's rated number one
by cnet wired in the verge it works on
phones laptops even routers
so everyone who shares your wi-fi can be
protected i love how easy expressvpn is
to use you just fire up the app you
click one button you're all set
i just like things that are too simple
for me to mess up it's not like
something that takes too much time or
active thought on a daily basis it's
just
straightforward secure your online
activity by visiting
expressvpn.comroguetoday that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
rogue and then you can get an extra
three months of uh expressway vm for
free
expressvpn.com rogue and our friends at
blue2 have a unique online service that
delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis but in
showable form and at a fraction of the
cost
blue chew is an online prescription
service so no doctor's office or
pharmacy trips it ships right to your
door
and a discreet package you sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you receive your
prescription within days their licensed
medical providers work with you to find
the right ingredient in strength if you
hate swallowing pills good news you can
get your boners from something that's
chewable
just like it says in the name bluetooth
so if you could benefit from some extra
confidence when it's time to perform
get hard as a rock visit bluetooth.com
for more details and important safety
information
and we got a special deal for our
audience try bluetooth free when you use
our promo code rogue check out just pay
five dollars in shipping you'll be
flashed no more that's bluetooth.com
promo code rogue to receive your first
month free and we thank bluetooth for
sponsoring this podcast
uh topic number two folks what if
what if uh is coming out in what
five days at this point we're super
excited um
and we know about many of the episodes
check out uh our episode of inside
marvel recently we gave a preview of the
season but um
of the episodes we know about from
trailer footage and from other
announcements interviews from the cast
i want to talk about which one might be
most impactful to the live-action side
of the marvel cinematic multiverse um
like because we know there's main
episode with doctor strange we know
there's a peggy carter
do you think it's more likely that we'll
see a live action peggy carter
captain uh kevin britton or captain
peggy carter whatever she is
or more likely that we'll see like a
live action marvel zombies
or a live-action uh like whatever
variant version of doctor strange we'll
see
and and uh what if how fun
it would be to finally get the marvel
zombies so
we have all these zombie movies coming
out right and we already know that james
gunn is doing great jobs at all these
things that he's doing
why not just throw him this money and be
like hey do you think you could do
marvel zombies and it'll just be like a
fun little spin-off
it'll be like to the side we don't
really need to make it cannon cannon
but do you know how much fun it would be
for james gunn to have that script and
to make this
property and it would be so much fun
and through the little trailer we see
that bucky is the main oh well like at
least it seems like that bucky seems to
be the
point of view for most of it he's like
at least one of the people that aren't
zombies he's just a normal
bucky um and if we do it through the
eyes of bucky if we do it through that
as a bucky or just one other superhero
that has to kill all the other zombie
superheroes
i think it would be like zombie movies
are becoming so this is coming from a
horror enthusiast but
zombie movies are becoming so much fun
and it's so great to like see that
mapping
for the mcu so i want to see it i want
to see it i think we could do it i think
it would be fun
well we also saw a little bit of zombie
hunter spider-man right like we we saw
some
sort of a bit in the trailer yeah and
then also they
released a lego that was legitimately
called
zombie hunter spider-man so oh
definitely some other
stuff going on with zombies there but
then i would feel like if there was a
zombie live action it would then be
spider-man i'm not sure though i feel
like they're gonna do a lot of stuff
with spidey
but but yeah i could see that some
zombies
and i could see it also leading up to
some secret wars type stuff yeah i feel
like you know that that whole realm of
like
zombies and vampires is something that
and the mcu was slowly creeping towards
so like i can totally see a marvel
zombies being implemented
into the mcu because like it we're
getting blade
and like you know i know blade's a
vampire hunter but like he can't be
hunting vampires forever
like he's got to have some other things
to hunt so like maybe zombies
zombies you see zombies zombies exactly
blade zombie hunter that'd be a crazy
what if like that'd be
nuts blade and spidey team up
oh my god zombies annoyed blade would be
spider-man
even better more reason to watch oh my
god exactly
but no um i do like i i do like the idea
of marvel zombies but i think that
um like something that really caught my
attention in the what if trailers are
those like weird
tentacle monsters that um captain carter
seems to be fighting
and i don't know exactly what those are
yet but
you know they really remind me of those
tentacles that tentacle monsters that
the guardians fought
in guardians too uh that came out the
obelisk the obelisk yes they
came out of that portal and so like that
it doesn't seem like
that it doesn't seem like a coincidence
to me like those two will probably
end up um i think that the technical
monitors is the bridge
for captain carter to uh go to the mcu
too so i think
it's probably most likely captain carter
being um
implemented more that's what i was
thinking too i mean we we have this
doctor strange episode
the uh spider-man in the show it's not
gonna be voiced by peter parker so we'll
just have to wait and see
uh i think there's always a very narrow
path for how spider-man will appear in
the mcu just because it's a sony own
character for the time being but uh for
doctor strange i feel like the doctor
strange episode
will very likely give us some clues on
how you know what the axis upon which
multiverse madness and potentially no
way home
in terms of the character of doctor
strange will work like how will function
are there are there gonna be alternate
sorcerers supreme that he meets
uh and whatever that multiverse crisis
will be so i'm most curious for that
but mt i think you bring up a really
good point that when it comes to just a
character
who we didn't expect to see in live
action anytime soon in the mcu
uh peggy carter the fact that like the
what if creators have talked about her
being a focal character to come back in
multiple seasons
i could totally see that character
becoming super popular in the animated
world
and then disney doing something like
what they did with the socatano
and thrawn and having like characters
that we knew as
animated characters now playing this
huge role in live action
even though peggy carter started as a
live-action character just using the
animated world to just be able to tell
new kinds of stories with with the
character and build up like a fan fervor
around them
so that then it's more of like a demand
issue as opposed to saying
someone who you previously knew as
captain america's girlfriend no
she's actually now i understand there's
already um
the agent carter series and
many of us love that show um but like
disney
for whatever reason is just like not
accepting agents of shield nation carter
is canon and i think they want to like
kind of reset the character as captain
carter
as already a kind of superhero so that
like we can now see maybe a captain
britain core
version of the character and less of a
spy espionage story with her
and more of a strip superhero story with
her i think captain car i i'm excited
even though this isn't captain carter
i'm excited to see where doctor
strange's what if we'll go to if we're
staying as canon as we want to be
because it seems like he's going to be
playing
a bad person and so we got yeah dark
darker strange right like she's got his
evil
his evil mode going on we've seen some
snippets of that
i feel like that could still be a
possibility
going forward and by being evil i mean
being evil as like the mcu sees evil so
like how we saw killmonger it's like
it's justified
don't come at me being like joshua
people no
no wow it's okay we like a complex
villain we do yeah
and i feel like between like
doctor strange is a person that does
follow the rules like obviously when he
was like i've seen
all these possibilities and the only one
i see working is one where like tony
stark dies
i think there's gonna be a situation and
what if where he's working with either a
bad person or he's following the rules
of a bad person and using his powers for
bad but it's in like a
in a really hard to understand villain
kind of perspective
which could go for further down the
series in the mcu
because again i think me and mt talked
about this
um kang needs someone to work with and i
think someone to work with
is either wanda or dr strange and so i
think there's an alternate timeline or
reality where they're using either wanda
or doctor strange and
and like to to defeat the other kings so
i think this is good go to that
we're talking rogue theory and this is
going to be really rogue
pop skip jump into rogueness but i think
hey
that could be why i i really like that
that take uh jessica i'm gonna give you
a uh a sparkle buck because i i like
your
zombies idea a lot i'd love to see a
live action marvel zombies
and i like this idea of uh kang wanting
to work with a partner mt i also like
your take that the uh
the potentially these tentacled monsters
are either the obelisk
i know before we've talked about the
many angled ones before too but uh this
idea of the abylus coming from they
talked about them as a trans-dimensional
monster you know which i think
is really interesting yeah the ability
to be a type of many angled one if
amongst the race yeah yeah for sure i
think that's a that's a great that's a
good point
um so things are all tied up right now
it's anyone's game
uh before we get to rogue questions we
want to thank our friends at upstart so
if you're carrying a credit balance
month after month
it can feel like you're in a never
ending cycle of debt like when lady siff
kept knee and loki and the groin in a
time loop
upstart can help make that final payment
so you can get ahead by the way thanks
to upstart of course for sponsoring this
episode
upstart is a fast and easy way to pay
off your debt with a personal loan all
online whether it's paying off credit
cards consolidating high interest debt
or funding personal expenses
over half a million people have used
upstart to get one fixed monthly payment
upstart knows you're more than just your
credit score and is expanding access to
affordable credit
unlike other lenders upstart considers
your income and current employment
to find you a smarter rate for your loan
with a five minute online rate check
you can see your rate up front for loans
between one thousand and fifty thousand
dollars you can receive funds as fast as
one business
day after accepting your loan find out
how upstart can lower your monthly
payments today when you go to
upstart.com
rogue that's upstart.com rogue don't
forget to use our url to let them know
that we sent you loan amounts will be
determined based on your credit income
and certain other information provided
in your loan application go to
upstart.com
rogue all right time for rogue questions
our question today is
in the lead-up to today's premiere of
suicide squad john cena has been wearing
his peacemaker costume pretty much
everywhere he even wore it to the film's
premiere in la this week
so the question is what actor
in this movie or in any movie uh should
have to
wear their character's outfit wherever
they go
tom hiddleston easily like lo people
love him as loki especially wearing the
horns like avengers one tom hiddleston
avengers one loki i mean people go crazy
over that man so i think it'd be fun
if you were just walking around with the
horns and everything cape and just like
that yeah my brain just jumped to
uh brendan fraser from the mummy for
some reason i feel like you should just
always
wear i don't know my brain just jumped
to them
like normal outfit yeah i was like okay
interesting i was like it'd be fun to
see if we made harrison ford dress up as
han solo even though he hates
it yeah honestly even worse put him as
indiana jones
at his age just running around but i
think it'd be fun
and this is staying on the suicide squad
still um i think it'd be fun to have the
woman that's playing rat catcher
um as the rat catcher because they're
just surrounded by rats so i think if he
kind of
that genuinely likes and is just running
around with a bunch of rants
it's like it's like the what is it the
piper the the
the piper yeah it's like watching that
but just like an anti version of it like
like a horror version of it i think
that'd be kind of funny i like that yeah
i like the idea i was thinking maybe
like tilda swinton from um the host snow
piercer
you know where she's got the weird teeth
and she's like oh
yeah every day till this one has to
dress up in a different costume that she
wore
that would be amazing because to see her
from doctor strange
kind of funny just wandering around i'd
be like what is going on
no one would question it no no no no
question
all right whatever yeah
can we say kate blanchett has to trip as
hella like oh my god
i walked down the hallway wouldn't be
able to walk through doors eric she
wouldn't it's too big
it's just too long so i would give her
my name and number every day i saw her
and she would shoot me down
oh my god she would stab me with one of
her attackers
our or hugh jackman could be wolverine
all the time what the heck
yeah i assume he already is yeah yeah i
think so
he just hasn't extended his claws he
just has to take off his shirt and just
start yelling
grab a cigar he's just yeah he's just
wolverine now
there's so many people that i would love
to see in their actual outfits
as like from a comedic standpoint yes
but then in like a genuine one
yeah i would choose brendan fager as
well brendan fraser from wasn't he
uh the jungle man whatever he was when
that's like another country who like
tries to do the rip-off
of the movie it's like thomas of the
woods
thomas thomas thomas swinging between
the trees he's just a christian watch
out for
that bush
he goes away hey
he's a cryptid he's friends with the
bears of the woods
i love it um would i produce it 100
yeah i think we yeah we got to get on
this um but i'm gonna give the
point to angelica trey because i think
we need i think brandon frazier would
look great
uh walking around uh and uh
and i i'm so happy to see he's getting
cast at everything now
yeah he was really great in um what's
the show called the dc one that
uh doom patrol patrolling thank you yeah
you just can't see
but i'm proud that he's getting work
that's what i'm proud of i don't care
what the content is
i'm glad he's turned back and he's doing
everything love you brandon frazier
if you're watching this i'll still marry
you come on the show brandon frazier
anyway go on the show um well that makes
angelica our winner today
congratulations angelica yeah
it's the a tray that's right
and that's that that's it for this
episode of rogue theory i want to thank
all of our guests
our winner angelica trey and of course
jessica clements and mt
follow all three of them on their social
media uh
send them some nice things support them
and everything they do and you can
support
our channel by checking out all of our
merch at new york stores merch.com
like what angelica's showing off our uh
for all time
uh looking fly angelica looking fly jet
ski mobius
wow looks great um and you can follow me
at ea boss you can follow new rockstars
and subscribe here on youtube thank you
so much for joining us this week and
we'll see you next time bye everybody
[Music]
foreign